You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost! Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water.
你曾说这里离水边只有几步路。我们只是还没找到那些路罢了。我们省了多少钱？够了。够去迷路的了！或者你也可以在希尔顿预订房间。欢迎来到你的海景房。距离水边仅几步之遥。
The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. Speaking of psychology is taking a winter break. So we're rerunning some of our favorite episodes from the past.
希尔顿特惠活动正在进行中。在Hilton.com或希尔顿App上预订，即可享高达8折优惠，获得你所期待的住宿体验。当你追求的是实惠，而不是惊吓。住哪里，这很关键。希尔顿，伴你每一次住宿。“心理学之谈”正在进行冬休。因此我们将重播过去的一些最爱节目。
In 2023, I talked to psychologists Daniel Simons and Christopher Shabree about why people fall for Ponzi schemes, fishing scams, and other cons, and what you can do to protect yourself. We hope you will enjoy this episode from the archives. Speaking of Psychology, we'll be back with new episodes in January. Thank you for listening. grabbing Ponzi schemes, to email fishing identity thieves, to fake news stories circulating on social media, it can sometimes seem like the world is full of people who want to deceive us. What many of these scammers and con artists have in common is that they take advantage of the patterns of thinking and the mental shortcuts that we all use in our daily lives. Most of the time, these mental habits
在2023年，我与心理学家丹尼尔·西蒙斯和克里斯托弗·沙布里探讨了为什么人们会陷入庞氏骗局、钓鱼诈骗和其他骗局，以及你可以采取什么措施来保护自己。我们希望你会喜欢这期来自档案的节目。“心理学之谈”将于一月带着新节目回归。谢谢收听。从庞氏骗局到电子邮件钓鱼、身份窃取，再到社交媒体上流传的假新闻，有时世界似乎充满了想要欺骗我们的人。这些骗子和江湖郎中所共有的特点是，他们利用了我们日常生活中都在使用的思维模式和心理捷径。大多数时候，这些心理习惯
serve us well. After all, most people aren't trying to trick us, and it would be difficult to go through life skeptical of everything and everyone. But the same habits of trust and belief that work well most of the time can leave us vulnerable when we encounter a con artist, a false news story, or some other type of deceit. So what are the cognitive habits that put us at risk of believing lies and falling prey to scams? Are some people simply more gullible than others or can anyone be conned? When you're offered something that sounds like an amazing opportunity, what questions should you ask to figure out if it's too good to be true? How common is fraud in the worlds of business, science, and elsewhere? Is technology, including artificial intelligence,
对我们大有帮助。毕竟，大多数人并不是在试图欺骗我们，如果对每件事、每个人都抱着怀疑态度，我们将很难在生活中前行。但正是这些在大多数时候运行良好的信任和信念习惯，当我们在遇到骗子、虚假新闻或任何其他形式的欺诈时，会让我们变得不堪一击。那么，有哪些认知习惯让我们面临相信谎言和沦为诈骗猎物的风险呢？有些人是不是天生就比其他人更容易轻信，还是任何人都会被骗？当你被提供一个听起来像是绝佳机会的契机时，你应该问自己什么问题来判断它是否好得不真实？商业、科学以及其他领域的欺诈现象有多普遍？包括人工智能在内的技术，
making it easier for people to cheat and lie and to get away with it? And what can we do to protect ourselves and our wallets by spotting scammers before it's too late? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines. the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. I have two guests today, co-authors of the new book, Nobody's Fool, Why We Get Taken in and What We Can Do About It. First is Dr. Daniel Simons, a professor of psychology and head of the visual cognition laboratory
是否在让人更容易作弊、撒谎并且逃脱惩罚？我们能做些什么来识别骗子，为时已晚之前保护好自己和钱包？欢迎收听“心理学之谈”，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。今天我有两位嘉宾，他们是新书《无人是傻瓜：我们为何受骗以及我们能做些什么》的合著者。首先是丹尼尔·西蒙斯博士，他是伊利诺伊大学厄巴纳-尚佩恩分校的心理学教授兼视觉认知实验室主任，在那里他还兼任广告系和商学院的荣誉教授。西蒙斯博士的研究探索了人类意识和记忆的局限性、我们经常意识不到这些局限性的原因，以及这些局限性对我们个人和职业生活的影响。接下来是克里斯托弗·沙布里博士，他是盖辛格卫生系统行为决策科学项目的教授兼联合主任。沙布里博士是一位认知科学家，其研究重点是决策、注意力、智力和行为遗传学。西蒙斯博士和沙布里博士也是2010年《纽约时报》畅销书《看不见的猩猩：我们的直觉如何欺骗我们》的合著者。他们合作研究了25年多，并花了将近十年时间撰写他们的新书，该书探讨了骗子、江湖郎中和其他骗子如何愚弄我们，以及我们可以做些什么来避免被骗。非常感谢二位今天加入我的节目。
at the University of Illinois Urbana-Champaign, where he also has courtesy appointments in the Department of Advertising and the College of Business. Dr. Simon's research explores the limits of human awareness and memory, the reasons we're often unaware of those limits, and the implications of those limits for our personal and professional lives. Next is Dr. Christopher Chabree, a professor and co-director of the Behavioral Decision Sciences Program at the Geisinger Health System. Dr. Chabry is a cognitive scientist whose research focuses on decision-making, attention, intelligence, and behavior genetics. Dr. Simons and Dr. Shebrey were also co-authors of the 2010 New York Times bestseller, The Invisible Gorilla, How Our Intuitions Deceive Us. They've collaborated on research for more than 25 years and spent nearly a decade working on their new book, which explores how scammers, con, artists, and other liars fool us and what we can do to avoid being taken in. Thank you both for joining me today.
谢谢邀请我们来。很高兴能来到这里。你们在书的开头引用了美国前国防部长詹姆斯·马蒂斯的一句话，他说：“偶尔我们所有人都会被某事愚骗。”他谈到的是他曾在声名狼藉的Theranos公司董事会任职的事实，当时该公司被揭发是一场骗局。所以让我们从这里开始。为什么我们所有人都会在至少某些时候容易受到欺骗？
Thanks for having us on. Great to be here. You start your book with a quote from James Mattis, the former U.S. Defense Secretary, who said, once in a while we can all be fooled by something. He was talking about the fact that he served on the board of the disgraced company, Theranos, before it was revealed as a fraud. So let's start there. Why is it that we're all vulnerable to being deceived, at least some of the time?
我想我们往往认为只有我们当中最轻信的人才会被欺骗，这是有充分理由的。每当你听到一个骗局或听说有人落入圈套时，事后看来，这一切似乎显而易见。你可以对自己说，哦，是的，我才不会上当呢。但大多数骗局并不是针对你的，对吧？它们是针对某个人的。当一个骗局确实是针对你个人量身定制、契合你的欲望、愿望和需求时，相比于不是针对你的情况，你更有可能上当受骗。
I think we tend to think that only the most gullible among us can be deceived, and there's good reason for that. Whenever you hear about a scam or you hear about somebody falling for a con, in retrospect, it seems obvious. And you can think to yourself, oh, yeah, I wouldn't have fallen for that. But most scams aren't targeting you, right? They're targeting somebody. And when a scam is really targeted to you in particular that meets your desires, your wishes, your wants, you're more likely to fall for it than if it's not.
因此，如果这种精准定位针对的是我们，并且它利用了我们的思考方式、我们正在寻找的信息，那么我们所有人都有可能受到欺骗。那么，沙布里博士，请教您，最常见的认知捷径或思维模式有哪些，会给我们带来麻烦？我认为我们讨论的第一个是真相偏差。真相偏差是指我们的默认倾向是认为我们听到、读到或遇到的一切都是真的，人们并不总是试图对我们说谎或欺骗我们。这是陷入任何种类的骗局、圈套或欺诈的先决条件，因为如果你相信你看到的一切都是假的、可疑的或误导性的，
So we all can be subject to being deceived if the targeting is. aimed at us, and it takes advantage of the way we think and the way and the information we're looking for. So, Dr. Chivri, let me ask you, what are some of the most common cognitive shortcuts or thinking patterns that get us into trouble? I think the first one that we talk about is truth bias. So truth bias is the idea that our default tendency is to think that whatever we hear or read or encounter is true, that people are not always trying to lie. to us or deceive us. And that's sort of a precondition for being taken in by any kind of scam or con or fraud, because if you believed everything you saw was false or questionable or misleading,
那么你实际上就不会根据那些提议、承诺、销售宣传和营销信息采取行动。拥有真相偏差对我们很重要，因为如果我们不倾向于接受其他人所说的话，我们将永远无法与他们制定计划、与他们交谈，或者除了时刻保持怀疑之外什么也做不了。一旦你从真相偏差开始，我们拥有的其他认知习惯就会给我们带来进一步的麻烦。我想首先强调的一个是我们的专注习惯，这指的是我们倾向于关注眼前、手头容易获得的信息，通常是别人提供给我们的信息，并仅根据这些信息做出决定，本质上是在假设
then you wouldn't really act on those offers and those promises and those sales pitches and those marketing messages. And truth bias is important for us to have because if we didn't tend to accept other people said we'd never be able to make plans with them, have a conversation with them or do anything really other than be skeptical all the time. Once you start with truth bias, then other cognitive habits we have can get us into further trouble. And I guess one I would highlight to start with is our habit of focus, which refers to our tendency to focus on information that's right in front of us that we have easily at hand, often that someone has provided to us, and make decisions based only on that information, operating essentially.
这就是全部重要的东西，或者这就是全部。避免被欺骗的主要方法之一是去思考别人没有向你展示的信息，或者缺失的、被隐瞒的信息，或者是你根本没有想到的信息，从而拓宽你的关注点，把除了此时此刻骗子或江湖郎中想让你关注的东西之外的其他信息也包含进来。因此，当你告诉人们他们无论如何都想相信的事情，或者与先入为主的观念相符的事情时，尤其容易愚弄他们。那么，我们怎么会陷入不愿意重新审视自己信念的陷阱呢？这是一个普遍的问题，对吧，我们往往对世界做出预测。我们必须这样做，
under the assumption that that's all that matters or that's all there is. And one of the main ways to avoid being deceived is to think about information that people aren't showing you or information that's missing or has been withhold or you're just not thinking about, broadening your focus to include other information besides perhaps what the scam or a con artist wants you to be focusing on at that particular moment. So it's especially easy to fool people when you tell them something that they want to believe anyway or something that matches the preconceived notion. So how can we fall into the trap of not being willing to re-examine our own beliefs? This is a general issue, right, that we tend to make predictions about the world. We have to,
对吧？我们必须对将要发生的事情有期望，并且我们可以根据这些期望采取行动。而且大多数时候，这样做是一件极好的事情。这对于大多数这类认知倾向来说都是真实的。它们通常对我们非常有效。只有当某人劫持它们来利用我们时，我们才会遇到问题。因此，预测和期望的问题在于，当某人给我们提供恰好是我们所寻找的东西时，我们往往不会像别人告诉我们与我们信仰相反的事情那样去质疑它。因此，如果你在Facebook、Instagram或任何地方看到的文章符合你的信念，你更有可能转发它，而不会停下来想一想，“嘿，这真的是真的吗，还是可能是假的？”即使在研究中，如果我们的发现看起来与我们的预期完全相反，我们往往也会更愿意
right? We have to have expectations for what's going to happen, and we can act on those. And most of the time, that's a great thing to do. And that's true for most of these sort of cognitive tendencies. They generally work really well for us. It's only when somebody is hijacking them to take advantage of us that we run into problems. So the problem with predictions and expectations is that when somebody gives us exactly what we're looking for, we don't tend to question it as much as we would if somebody told us the opposite of what we believe. So you're much more likely to forward that story on Facebook or Instagram or wherever if it matches your beliefs without stopping to think, hey, is that really true or might it be false? Even in research, we tend to be much more willing to
去质疑我们的发现，而不是当它们完全如我们所预测的那样出现时。而这种不进行自我双重检查的倾向会给我们带来麻烦。嗯，你刚刚提到了科学界，我知道在你们书中举了几个科学家的例子，其中不幸也包括心理学家，他们在某些情况下多年来一直侥幸逃脱欺诈和欺骗。怎么做到的？你已经透露了。科学欺诈有多普遍，当非科学家试图阅读和理解他们在经常浏览的出版物中可能读到的科学新闻时，他们应该如何看待这一点？
question our findings if it looks like they came out the opposite of what we were expecting, than if they came out exactly as we predicted. And that tendency to just not double-check ourselves can get us into trouble. Well, you just mentioned the world of science, and I know in your book you've given several examples of scientists, including psychologists, unfortunately, who have gotten away with fraud and deception in some cases for many years. How? How do you have, you've given a way. How common is scientific fraud and how should non-scientists think about this when they're trying to read and make sense of the science news that they may be reading in publications that they look at all the time?
我不知道我们是否有关于科学欺诈基本发生率的良好估计，因为并非所有欺诈行为都被揭露了。所以我们不能回到，你知道，过去10万篇出版物中去清点有多少是欺诈性的或有其他类型的人为捏造之类的。因此，它可能比迄今为止检测到的案例所让你相信的要更普遍，但它可能也不像科学界一些最大的批评者希望你相信的那样普遍。我认识的大多数科学家，我确信丹认识的科学家以及世界上大多数科学家，都在努力获得准确的结果。他们试图报告他们实际做的事情。他们并没有故意伪造事情。
I don't know if we have a good estimate of what the base rate of scientific fraud is because it hasn't all been uncovered. So we can't go back to, you know, the last 100,000 publications and count up how many were fraudulent or had other kinds of fabrications or anything like that. So it's probably more common than the detected cases so far would have you believe, but it's probably not as common as some of the biggest critics of scientific fields would want you to believe either. Most scientists that I know, and I'm sure that Dan knows and most scientists in the world, are trying to get accurate results. They're trying to report what they actually did. They're not deliberately falsifying things.
但在一个可以合理预期所报告的科学结果是诚实、真实而非虚假的环境中，少数人可以设法将自己塞进这个过程中，并故意制造一些东西，然后侥幸过关，你知道的，将捏造的结果带入文献中。我认为普通大众如果发现特定科学结果带有诸如“这是基于非常小的样本量”、“这基于单项研究”、“它尚未得到独立研究人员的重复验证”、“它在媒体上被炒作得非常厉害，然而似乎没有人能够重现这些发现”、“它通过非常微小的干预产生了巨大的影响”等迹象时，就应该对这些结果保持怀疑。这表明某些东西可能是
But in a climate where it's reasonable to expect that scientific results that are reported are honest and true and not false, a few people can get away with inserting themselves into the process and deliberately creating things that will then slip through and, you know, get fabricated results into the literature. I think that the general public should be skeptical of specific scientific results if they detect signs like, well, this is based on a very small sample size. it's based on a single study. It hasn't replicated by independent researchers. It's getting hyped quite a lot in the media, and yet nobody else seems to be able to reproduce these findings. It has a gigantic impact from a very tiny intervention. That's a sign that something might be
被夸大或误导性的，甚至可能是编造的。但是，当你遇到那些真正仔细审视了工作并在多年里做了数十项、数百项、数千项研究的大型科学家团体的普遍审慎意见时，这些才是人们真正应该信任和依赖的事情。我想补充一点，我们往往会有这样一种印象：发现是由于单一发现中的灵光一现而发生的。而这并不是科学中发现的工作原理，对吧？如果我们想声称某事是心理学中关于人的真理，这通常是我们想要做的。我们想要说这是关于人、他们的行为、
overblown or misleading or perhaps even made up. But when you encounter sort of the general considered opinions of large bodies of scientists who've really looked careful, at work and done, you know, dozens, hundreds, thousands of studies over years, those are the kinds of things that people should really, should really trust and rely on. Just add to that, that we tend to have this impression that discoveries happen in a bolt of insight in a single finding. And that's not how discovery in science works, right? If we want to make a claim that something is a truth about people in psychology, that's often what we want to do. We want to say this is a truth about people, their behavior,
他们的信念、他们的特性的真理，你通常不会从一项研究中就对所有人得出明确的结论，尤其是非常小的研究。发现涉及对一个概念的渐进式理解，并在广泛的语境中对其进行测试，以确保它确实适用得更广泛。它可能是关于某个特定时间的一个微小样本的发现，也许吧，但如果你不测试它是否普遍适用于许多语境和许多人，它就不是我们在科学中所倾向于认为的广泛发现。因此，我会对单一研究保持警惕。这是一项告诉了我们以前不知道的事情而且以前从没有人想到过的新研究。
their beliefs, their traits, you're not going to typically come to a definitive conclusion about all people from one study, especially very small studies. Discovery involves sort of incremental understanding of an idea and testing it in a wide range of contexts to make sure it actually applies more broadly. It might be a discovery about one tiny little sample at one time, maybe, but if you don't test whether it's general to a lot of contexts and to a lot of people, It's not really a broad discovery in the sense that we tend to think of in science. So I would be wary of single studies. This is a new study that's told us something that we didn't know before and that nobody ever thought of before.
这往往是被过度炒作的事情。现在，许多骗局都涉及承诺好得不真实的丰厚回报，例如提供前所未闻回报率的投资机会，或者承诺奇迹般医学治疗的公司。如果你被提供了一个听起来像是绝佳机会的契机，那么为了决定它是否落入“好得不真实”的类别，你应该问自己哪些问题？我可以从这里开始。我们都知道，当一件事好得不真实时，我们就不应该相信它。这是每个人都知道的事情，如果它看起来好得不真实，那它很可能就是假的。问题在于，对一个人来说听起来好得不真实的事情，对另一个人来说可能刚刚好。
That tends to be something that's getting overhyped. Now, a lot of scams involve promising something that's too good to be true, like an investment opportunity that offers unheard of returns or a company that promises a miracle medical cure. if you're offered something that sounds like an amazing opportunity, what are the questions to ask yourself to decide if it falls into that too good to be true category? I can start with that. We all know that when something is too good to be true, we shouldn't believe it. That's something that everybody kind of knows that if it seems too good to be true, it probably is. The problem is what sounds too good to be true to one person is just good enough for another person.
因此，对其他人而言，他们会觉得这足够合理，从而直接跳进坑里。决定一件事情何时好得不真实的挑战在于，确保你从一开始就以一种怀疑的眼光来看待它。所以，如果某件事看起来非常有前途、非常惊人，你应该退后一步，问问自己：“为了验证这确实是真的，我需要知道什么？”我们知道，如果有人向你提供50%的投资回报率，并且保证在一年内没有任何损失。几乎肯定不是真的，因为没有投资是这样的。所以你可以退后一步，问问：他们必须做些什么才能提出这种说法？
So for somebody else, they're going to find that as just plausible enough that they're going to jump in. The challenge in deciding when something's too good to be true is in making sure that you view it kind of skeptically from the beginning. So if something seems really promising, really amazing, you should take a step back and say, what would I need to know in order to verify that that's actually true? We know that if somebody offers you 50% returns on your investment with a guarantee, of no losses all within a year. Almost certainly not true because no investment does that. So you can take a step back and say, what would they have to be doing to be able to make that claim?
一旦你开始对它产生一点质疑，你可能会意识到，不，这实际上真的好得不真实。我正想说，伯尼·麦道夫的案子怎么样？当时这好得不真实，然而他一直在向人们支付收益。所以除了“市场表现没有这么好，然而我每年仍然获得15%的回报”之外，你真的没有理由去质疑。我的意思是，你怎么能逃脱那种情况？因此，正如丹所说，好得不真实对不同的人可能意味着不同的事情，但有一些迹象对于好得不真实的事物来说是相当普遍的，
And as soon as you start questioning it a little bit, you might realize that now this really actually is too good to be true. I was just going to say, what about the case of Bernie Madoff where it was too good to be true and yet he was paying people? So you didn't really have a reason to question other than, well, the market isn't behaving this well, and yet I'm still getting 15% returns every year. I mean, how do you escape being in a situation like that? So too good to be true, as Dan said, can mean different things to different people, but there are some signs that are pretty common for things that are too good to be true,
或者至少是不应该被相信的。就伯尼·麦道夫而言，他所提供的实际上并不一定太好。这不是一个非常巨大的回报率。那是每年8%到12%，这比股市的长期平均水平略高一点，但高得不多。这与最初的庞氏骗局所提供的，或者近年来很多加密货币提供的回报完全不可同日而语。但明显的迹象是，这是每年如此。从来没有出现过亏损的年份。甚至几乎从来没有出现过亏损的月份。
or at least that shouldn't be believed. And in the case of Bernie Madoff, what he was offering wasn't really necessarily too good. It was not a really huge rate of return. It was 8 to 12% a year, which is a little bit above the long run average of the stock market, but not too much. It's nothing like what an original Ponzi scheme was offering or what a lot of cryptocurrency offers the, you know, recently have offered. But the telltale sign was that it was every single year. There was never a losing year. There was barely ever even a losing month.
他设法使投资者投资的回报率，你知道的，契合在那个狭窄的区间内。因此，我认为正是那里的过度一致性困住了人们。他们认为，这是一桩稳赚不赔的买卖。我永远不会亏损。我每年都会拿到相同的金额。有点像国库券、某种债券或储蓄账户，但只是具有高得多的回报率。我认为这就是创新。
He managed to make the returns on his investors' investments, you know, fit within that narrow band. So the excessive consistency there was, I think, what trapped people. They thought, this is a sure thing. I will never lose. I'll get the same amount per year. Kind of like a treasury bill or some kind of bond or savings account, but just with a much higher rate of return. And that was, I think, the innovation.
就像，麦道夫的真正新奇之处——这被称为庞氏骗局，但有些人称之为麦道夫骗局，因为他确实增加了一个新维度，即不向人们提供那些有文化的人、可能在股市呆了一段时间的人知道是不切实际的荒谬主张，比如半年或一年内获得50%的回报之类的主张。而是提供一些看起来合理得多的东西。就他们赚到的总金额而言，它并不是好得不真实。就他们赚取这些金额的持续性而言，它才是好得不真实。因此，持续性或其缺乏是欺诈的一个重要标志，人们可以比平时更多地关注这一点。这在科学中也会发生，对吧？因此，临床试验中欺诈的一个标志是，如果基线条件——在开始时对人们进行测量时——你经常会进行检查，以确保分配到治疗组和安慰剂组的人在其他方面是相同的，这样这些因素就不会污染你的治疗效果。所以你有点期望两组人在先前的健康状况或年龄等方面保持平衡。如果它们完全平衡，
Like, really the true novelty of Madoffs, it's called a Ponzi scheme, but some people call it a Madoff scheme because he really added this new dimension of not offering people the ridiculous proposition. that educated people, maybe who've been in the stock market for a while know is unrealistic, the 50% in six months or a year or something like that. But offering something that seems much more reasonable, it wasn't too good to be true in the sense of the total amount of money they made. It was too good to be true in the sense of the consistency with which they made it. So consistency or the lack of it is an important sort of sign of fraud that people can, you know, pay more attention to than they might otherwise. That happens in science too, right? So one of the hallmarks of fraud in clinical trials is if the baseline conditions, when people are measured at the beginning, you'll often do checks to make sure that the people assigned to the treatment and the placebo group were the same in other ways so that those aren't sort of contaminating the effects of your treatment. So you kind of expect the two groups to be balanced on prior health conditions, for example, or age. And if they're all perfectly balanced, That's weird. That's a red flag because just by chance, if you randomly assign people to groups, they won't all end up perfectly balanced. You'll end up with a distribution, with some differing on some factors and not on others. And it's turned out that that's been a major way of finding fraud in a number of disciplines from anesthesiology to any field that has clinical medical trials. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer
那就很奇怪了。这是一个危险信号，因为纯粹凭运气，如果你随机将人分配到各组，他们不会最终都达到完美的平衡。你会得到一个分布，其中一些人在某些因素上有所不同，而在其他因素上则没有。事实证明，这是从麻醉学到任何进行临床医学试验的领域的许多学科中发现欺诈的主要方法。你的夏天现在从家得宝（The Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日促销开始。是时候点燃夏日了，
cookouts with the next grill four-burner gas grill on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. So your book warrants people to be wary of the butterfly effect. What do you mean by this?
用Next Grill四燃烧器燃气烤炉，特价仅需199美元。整个季节尽情款待，只需499美元即可购买汉普顿湾（Hampton Bay）韦斯特格罗夫（West Grove）七件套户外餐桌椅。今年阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受保证低价。售完即止，价格有效期为5月14日至5月27日，仅限美国，不适用情况请参阅详情。访问Home Depot.com/price match了解详情。因此，你们的书警告人们要警惕蝴蝶效应。你们这是什么意思？
that. Well, so the old anecdote goes that a butterfly flapping its wings in Brazil can cause a tornado in Texas. And that's based on sort of old, well, not old, but relatively new ideas about chaos theory and, you know, certain attempts to model how, you know, small changes in one place can perturb a system so that some dramatic thing happens someplace else. People tend to be too accepting of the idea that tiny little intervention. in the world, not random things like butterflies flapping their wings, but, you know, maybe very small, very small, very brief interventions. For example, giving like a half hour or an hour long sort of like reflective exercise at the beginning of college can cause big changes in people's GPA and, you know, willingness to stay in
嗯，古老的轶事说，巴西的一只蝴蝶扇动翅膀可以在德克萨斯州引发一场龙卷风。这基于陈旧的——嗯，也不是陈旧的，但相对较新的关于混沌理论的想法，你知道的，某些试图模拟一个地方的小变化如何扰乱系统，从而在其他地方发生某些戏剧性事情的尝试。人们往往过于轻信这样的想法：微小的干预
college and complete the degree and so on, just to give one example of this class of, of this class of effects. Another one is priming studies, the idea that sort of very brief exposures to stimuli we don't notice or remember encountering can dramatically change our behaviors or beliefs, you know, just a few seconds, minutes, or even longer or later. There's one particular dramatic example where a study claimed that subliminally seeing the Israeli flag caused people to be more likely to vote and vote for centrist. parties as opposed to, as opposed to more extreme parties, you know, days, weeks later in an actual election. And that's just the kind of thing that you should look up and say, how plausible is it that something that happened to you for 150 milliseconds, you know, in October, changed, you know, what you did in the voting booth in November? And there are many, many studies and stories like this, which we sort of take to mean that there's an inherent appeal to the idea that we could discover
在世界上——不是像蝴蝶扇动翅膀那样随机的事情，而是，你知道的，也许是非常小、非常小、非常短暂的干预。例如，在大学刚开始时进行半小时或一小时左右的反思性练习，就能对人们的GPA、留在大学并完成学位意愿等产生重大改变，这只是这类效果的一个例子。另一个是启动研究，即对我们没有注意到或不记得遇到过的刺激进行非常短暂的曝光，可以戏剧性地改变我们的行为或信念，你知道的，就在几秒钟、几分钟、甚至更长时间之后。有一个特别戏剧性的例子，一项研究声称，在潜意识中看到以色列国旗会导致人们更有可能投票，并且投票给温和派
these little tiny things that made a vast difference. And if we did discover them, that would be great, right? It's not irrational to say we should want tiny cheap things that make, you know, huge outcomes. A vaccine is one of those things, right? It's a tiny little injection that you get once that might prevent you from getting a disease for the rest of your life in some cases. It's just that those are rare, those are rare events in science. They're not the things that are coming out every day in our psychology journals, unfortunately. And that's a sort of general principle, that anytime you see a big effect from a small intervention, that's when you should require the strongest evidence. You shouldn't go to the bank on a single study showing something like that because the odds are good
政党，而不是投票给更极端的政党，你知道的，几天、几周后在实际选举中。这正是那种你应该去查证并说的事情：在十月份发生在你身上150毫秒的事情，改变了你在十一月份投票站做的事情，这有多大可能性？有许多许多像这样的研究和故事，我们将其理解为，我们有一种内在的吸引力，倾向于认为我们可以发现
in those sorts of cases that it's not going to replicate in the same way that we think we are, or it's not going to be general in the way that it was claimed. Those are going to be the effects that are sort of really engaging and exciting and more likely to be wrong because it's really rare to have giant effect sizes from tiny little variation, tiny little interventions. So do either of you have a favorite con or scam you came across in researching the book? And I'm using the word favorite in air quotes here. And why is it your favorite and what can we learn from it? I'll start with one that I knew about before we started writing the book, but I learned a lot more about it in researching the book.
这些产生巨大差异的微小事物。如果我们确实发现了它们，那就太好了，对吧？说我们应该想要产生巨大结果的微小且廉价的东西，这并不是不理性的。疫苗就是其中之一，对吧？它是一次注射的微小针剂，在某些情况下可能会阻止你在余生中感染某种疾病。只是这些事件在科学中很少见。不幸的是，它们并不是每天都出现在我们心理学期刊上的东西。这是一个普遍原则，即每当你看到小干预产生大效果时，这就是你应该需要最强有力证据的时候。你不应该把钱押在显示这种结果的单一研究上，因为在这些情况下，其概率很高
that's the famous case of John von Neumann. You may have heard of John von Neumann as a famous economist, mathematician, computer scientist, game theorist, one of really the fathers of sort of modern science. But it was also the name taken by a guy who entered a chess tournament in 1993 under that name. I don't think it was his real name, but he entered a chess tournament under that name. In 1993, this was 30 years ago. Actually, 30 years ago this month, in fact, July my 1993, and nobody had ever heard of the guy before. He didn't even play chess. He didn't even touch the pieces and move the pieces as though he had ever played in the chess tournament before. He looked like a complete outsider and novice. And yet he drew with a grandmaster and beat
它不会以我们认为的那样复制，或者它不会以所声称的那样具有普遍性。这些将是那种非常吸引人、令人兴奋且更有可能是错误的效果，因为从微小变异、微小干预中获得巨大的效应量是非常罕见的。那么，你们俩在研究这本书的过程中有没有遇到过最喜欢的骗局或诈骗？这里我用引号里的“最喜欢”这个词。为什么它是你最喜欢的，我们能从中学到什么？我先讲一个我在开始写书之前就知道的，但在研究这本书的过程中我了解得更多的骗局。
masters and was doing really well in this chess tournament. And in fact, tied for a prize at the end. He didn't win every game. Some games he would just sort of like suddenly like stop playing for no reason for 40 minutes and just let his time run out, or some games he would try to make illegal moves and just sort of stop and at the end of the tournament, though, he had won enough games to win a prize, but everybody was suspicious about how this guy could be doing it. And so they didn't really know exactly how, but they thought he couldn't, like this, this can't happen. So the tournament director, a guy named Bill Goichberg, who I've actually known since the very first
那是约翰·冯·诺伊曼的著名案子。你可能听说过约翰·冯·诺伊曼是著名的经济学家、数学家、计算机科学家、博弈论专家，确实是现代科学之父之一。但这也是一个在1993年以该名字参加国际象棋比赛的人所使用的名字。我想这不是他的真名，但他以那个名字参加了国际象棋比赛。在1993年，那是30年前。实际上，正好是30年前的这个月，也就是1993年7月，以前从来没有人听说过这个人。他甚至都不会下棋。他甚至没有像以前参加过国际象棋比赛那样去触摸和移动棋子。他看起来完全是个局外人和新手。然而，他与特级大师下成了平局，击败了
chess tournament I played in, didn't want to give money to this guy who he thought might be cheating somehow, but you didn't know whether he was cheating or how he was cheating. So he set up on the chessboard, before writing him a check, he set up on the chess board a very simple chess puzzle that a five-year-old who had learned the game, you know, a month earlier could probably have solved. And he refused to even try it and he walked out and essentially was never seen before. And so the reason why I love that con so much, and it's generally agreed now that basically what the guy was doing was probably concealing an earpiece and getting information transmitted to him by an accomplice. And so he's who was using a computer to help figure out what moves to play and was sort of sending code to him, like through an earpiece saying, you know, move this piece from here to there. But if the transmission broke down, he would just stop and wait to hear something, you know, and so that didn't help him solve the puzzle at the end, you know. So what the lesson that we drew from this for, for what you can do yourself is, you know, it would be tempting to just write the check and move on, you know, and our habit of efficiency sort of leads us to sort of just, you know, move on with things.
大师们，在这个国际象棋比赛中表现得非常好。事实上，最后还并列获得了奖项。他并不是赢了每一局。有些局他会无缘无故地突然停止下棋40分钟，任由他的时间耗尽，或者有些局他会试图走违规的棋然后突然停下来。不过，在比赛结束时，他赢得的比赛足以赢得一个奖项，但每个人都对这个人怎么能做到这一点产生怀疑。所以他们并不真正知道具体是如何做到的，但他们认为他不能——这不可能发生。因此，赛事主管，一个名叫比尔·戈伊奇伯格的人——我实际上自我参加的第一场
like make quick decisions and so on, but Goitschberg thought to ask one more question of this guy and do a little tiny test and see whether he really was what he purported to be that as a chess master. And in, you know, in 10 seconds, he had his answer, right, when the guy refused to do it and started arguing and left. So we advise anybody to really think about what questions you could ask. Sometimes it only takes just one to get a crucial additional piece of information that will let you decide whether you're being conned or scammed or whether something is, legitimate. And that's just my favorite example because of the whole story that surrounds it. Yeah. I could talk about one that I think is more likely to be encountered by you or me,
国际象棋比赛起就认识他了——不想把钱给这个他认为可能在某种程度上作弊的人，但你不知道他是否在作弊或者他是如何作弊的。因此，在给他写支票之前，他在棋盘上摆出了一个非常简单的国际象棋残局，一个刚学了一个月这门游戏的五岁小孩可能都能解开。而他甚至拒绝尝试，直接走了出去，基本上再也没有露面。因此，我们从中为你能做的事情得出的教训是，直接写支票然后继续前进是很诱人的，你知道的，我们的高效习惯导致我们倾向于，你知道的，继续处理事情，
right, which is what's known as a call center scam. And these are scams that we all have encountered. So if you've gotten calls asking you to call back to extend your car's warranty, right? The vast majority of those are scams, right? Because, you know, most of us don't need to do that. and you've probably never called back that number. But anybody who does has selected themselves as somebody who is likely, or more likely at least, to send money. It's the same way that the famous Nigerian email scam works, that it looks ridiculous on its face to most people.
比如快速做出决定等等，但戈伊奇伯格却想到要对这家伙多问一个问题，并做了一个微小的测试，看看他是否真的是他所宣称的国际象棋大师。在，你知道的，10秒钟内，他就得到了答案，对吧，当这家伙拒绝做并开始争吵然后离开时。因此，我们建议任何人都要认真思考你可以问什么问题。有时只需要一个问题就能获得至关重要的额外信息，让你能够决定自己是被骗了还是被诈骗了，或者某件事是否是合法的。这就是我最喜欢的例子，因为围绕它的整个故事。是的。我可以谈谈一个我认为你我更有可能遇到的骗局，
But it doesn't have to convince most people. It only has to convince the people who find it really appealing and who are most likely to fall for that particular pitch. So you can send out millions of emails and only reach a tiny, number of people who are going to send back their and respond, but that's exactly what you want, right? You only want to interact with the people who are most likely to give you their bank account number. But call center scams have taken on a new form, which is to put people under huge time pressure and threaten them. So, for example, saying, you owe money to the IRS, and unless you
对吧，也就是所谓的呼叫中心诈骗。这些是我们所有人都遇到过的骗局。所以，如果你接到电话要求你回电以延长你的汽车保修期，对吧？其中绝大多数都是骗局，对吧？因为，你知道的，我们大多数人不需要这样做。而且你可能从来没有回拨过那个号码。但任何这样做的人都把自己挑选成了可能——或者至少更有可能——汇钱的人。这与著名的尼日利亚电子邮件诈骗的工作方式相同，它对大多数人来说表面上看起来很荒谬。
pay it right now, the police will come knock down your door. Right. And what they often will ask people to do is go out and buy a prepaid cash card and then read the number over the phone. Most people aren't going to follow for that, but they're really good at their pressure tactics so that if you feel like you're in danger, if you feel like you've maybe done something wrong and you're not sure, there's a really strong pressure to just pay up and be done with it. But of course, as soon as you pay up, they're going to be asking you for more money. And I think it's a really interesting case because this has been a really successful industrial-sized business fraud that's been happening.
但它不需要说服大多数人。它只需要说服那些觉得它极具吸引力、最容易落入该特定宣传陷阱的人。所以你可以发送数百万封电子邮件，却只能联系到一小部分会回复的人，但那正是你想要的，对吧？你只想与最有可能把银行账号给你的人互动。但呼叫中心诈骗采取了一种新形式，即把人们置于巨大的时间压力下并威胁他们。例如，说：你欠国税局钱，除非你
But people should keep in mind that no government agency or formal corporation or any organization that's asking you for money will ever ask you to go buy a cash card and read a number over the phone, ever. That's always a scam. Nobody's going to ask you to go out and buy cash cards. The other thing is that there's never going to be a case where somebody's going to call and allow you to pay off if the police are on their way to your door. The IRS doesn't send the police to your door based on a phone call and not paying immediately. There's never that much rush. But these call centers have refined their techniques to put you under a huge amount of pressure so that you want to just make them go away. And that's been a really effective tactic.
立刻付清，否则警察就会上门砸门。对吧。而且他们经常会要求人们做的是出去买一张预付费现金卡，然后在电话里把卡号读出来。大多数人不会上当，但他们的施压战术非常高明，如果你觉得你处于危险之中，如果你觉得自己可能做错了什么而又不敢确定，就会有一种非常强烈的压力想要赶快付钱了事。但当然，你一付钱，他们就会向你索要更多的钱。我认为这是一个非常有趣的案例，因为这是一个非常成功、工业化规模的商业欺诈，一直在发生。
So if you get that sort of a call, you can safely hang up because if it's true, they're going to email you, they're going to send you a letter. They're going to ask you to react in some formal way. And you can call the official number, look it up on the lab yourself. Don't call the number they give you. Look it up online. and called the official number and see if it's real. It's more often than not, it's not. Dan's story is a great example of, I think,
但人们应该记住，没有任何政府机构、正式公司或任何向你索要钱财的组织会要求你去买一张现金卡并在电话里读出一个号码，绝无可能。这永远都是骗局。没有人会叫你出去买现金卡。另一件事是，绝对不会出现有人打电话来，而如果警察正在去你家的路上却允许你花钱消灾的情况。国税局不会仅仅根据一个电话以及没有立即付款就派警察去你家。从来没有这么紧急。但这些呼叫中心改进了他们的技术，给你施加巨大的压力，让你只想让他们消失。这是一种非常有效的战术。
why we sort of fall for this gullibility myth, right? Because we hear a story like this and we think, I would never believe that the IRS is sending the police to my door to collect my tax bill with Apple, you know, with Apple, iTunes cards or, you know, whatever. Who are these people who fall for this stuff? Well, of course, I'm a scientist, and scientists have been defrauded. But they've been defrauded in a different way from that. They've been defrauded by people who understood how to defraud scientists by making up plausible research results and getting them past, you know, peer review and so on.
所以如果你接到那样的电话，你可以放心地挂断，因为如果是真的，他们会给你发电子邮件，他们会给你寄信。他们会要求你以某种正式的方式做出反应。你可以拨打官方号码，自己在网上查一下。不要打他们给你的号码。在网上查一下，
So everybody can get conned and scammed, but the way is going to be specific to everybody. And people who think they're sophisticated and superior, they can be tricked in other ways. Maybe not by that con. Like, you know, there's something out there for, you know, something out there for all of us in the world of scams, unfortunately. I mentioned AI in my introduction as a kind of technology that may be making it. easier for people to cheat and lie in all sorts of new ways, such as students using chat GPT to write their papers or people using AI tools to write fake news stories or doctor photos and videos. Do you think AI is going to lead to a big rise in deceptions and scams of
然后拨打官方号码，看看它是否是真的。十有八九，它不是。丹的故事是一个很好的例子，我认为，为什么我们容易陷入这种轻信的神话，对吧？因为我们听到这样一个故事，然后我们想，我绝不会相信国税局会派警察到我家门口用苹果（Apple）iTunes卡或，你知道的，诸如此类的东西来收缴我的税单。到底是什么样的人会落入这种把戏？当然，我是个科学家，科学家也被骗过。但他们被骗的方式与此不同。他们被骗是因为有些人懂得如何通过捏造似是而非的研究成果并让它们通过同行评审等环节来欺骗科学家。
all kinds or even new kinds? I think one of the themes that we've run across over and over in researching this work is that the same principles have applied to scams as long back as you can look. So the same sorts of taking advantage of our habits and hooking us with the information we find appealing, that's been true going back to the Trojan horse. So there's not anything new in that sense. There are new variants of old scams that merge all the time. And AI might allow some new variants of scams to become much more potent. So here's one case where I think it's particularly going to be problematic. There's a scam right now that's been pretty effective that I sometimes call an injury scam or a kidnapping scam
所以每个人都可能被骗和被诈骗，但骗局的形式将因人而异。自以为老练和优越的人，可以用其他方式被愚弄。也许不是那种骗局。就像，你知道的，在诈骗的世界里，总有一款适合我们所有人，不幸的是。我在介绍中提到人工智能是一种可能使人更容易作弊和撒谎并以各种新方式作弊的技术，例如学生使用ChatGPT写论文，或者人们使用人工智能工具写假新闻故事或篡改照片和视频。你认为人工智能会导致各种欺诈和骗局的大幅增加，甚至是新类型的增加吗？我认为我们在研究这项工作时一遍又一遍遇到的一大主题是，同样的原则自古以来就一直适用于骗局。同样是利用我们的习惯，用我们觉得有吸引力的信息来吸引我们，这可以追溯到特洛伊木马。所以从这个意义上说，并没有什么新鲜事。旧骗局的新变种一直在不断涌现。人工智能可能会让一些骗局的新变种变得更具破坏力。这里有一个我认为尤其会成问题的案例。现在有一个非常有效的骗局，我有时称之为受伤骗局或绑架骗局，
where somebody calls up a parent or a grandparent and says, your kid's been in an accident, we need you to send money right away so we can get them treatment at this hospital. It's not actually a hospital. And again, it's a time pressure, preying on fears, praying on your desire to kind of help right away. Often that sort of scam depends on people being targeted because they know their kid isn't home
即某人打电话给父母或祖父母，说：“你的孩子出了事故，我们需要你马上汇钱，以便我们在医院给他治疗。”这实际上并不是医院。同样，这也是一种时间压力，利用恐惧，利用你想要马上提供帮助的愿望。通常这种骗局取决于人们被作为目标，因为他们知道自己的孩子不在家。
and they're taking advantage of a little bit of information they've picked up about the parents and the kid on social media. But imagine how powerful that can be if instead of calling up and having it be somebody else that you don't know making that call, if it's a synthesized version of your kid's voice, makes it that much more believable. So I think a lot of these sorts of things potentially could be amplified as AI capabilities improve and develop. So, yeah, that's a concern. And there are things you can do to kind of try and prevent that in advance. One thing I've talked about with my family is having a passcode for our family so that if we ever are in doubt whether this is true, you just ask for the passcode.
他们利用了在社交媒体上搜集到的一些关于父母和孩子的信息。但想象一下，如果打电话来的不是一个你并不认识的陌生人，而是你孩子声音的合成版本，那会有多大威力，这会让骗局变得更加可信。所以我认为，随着人工智能能力的提高和发展，许多这类手段可能会被放大。所以，是的，这是一个令人担忧的问题。你可以采取一些措施来提前预防这种情况。我和家人讨论过的一件事是，设立一个家庭密码，这样如果我们对某个事情是否真实产生怀疑，只需索要密码即可。
And if they don't give it to you, it's a scam. That's a good trick. And here we are putting our voices out there on the Internet for everyone to copy. One of the things that we do at the American Psychological Association is our IT department sends fake fishing emails to employees. and you're supposed to report them as a training exercise, and of course there are always people who fall for them. Do these strategies work? I mean, can you really be taught to avoid to be alert to scams?
如果他们给不出密码，那就是一场骗局。这真是个好把戏。而我们却把自己的声音公之于我们在互联网上，供所有人复制。我们在美国心理学会做的事情之一，就是由我们的IT部门向员工发送虚假的网络钓鱼电子邮件。作为一项培训练习，你理应举报这些邮件，当然，总会有人上当受骗。这些策略真的管用吗？我的意思是，你真的能通过培训学会避免和警惕骗局吗？
I think you can. I mean, you could start by reading our book. But often, you know, the specifics of a particular scam, those will evolve and change over time, right? So these particular phishing emails that, you know, that the IT department sends are designed to kind of look like the phishing emails that the people who run these business email compromise scams are using these days, they won't perhaps permanently inoculate you against every kind of scam. But I think
我认为是可以的。我的意思是，你可以从阅读我们的书开始。但通常情况下，特定骗局的具体细节会随着时间的推移而演变和改变，对吧？因此，IT部门发送的这些特定钓鱼邮件，旨在模仿目前经营这些商业电子邮件诈骗的人所使用的钓鱼邮件。它们或许不能永远让你对每一种骗局都免疫。但我认为
they're a reasonable form of training. And they also help to generate information like 25% of your colleagues fell for this thing, which can maybe raise awareness more broadly if the scale of the susceptibility is known. And there have been various research studies that have found surprisingly high percentages of people willing to turn over their passwords and other credentials. to these kinds of scams. But they're not a permanent solution. I think to the extent there is a permanent solution, it really involves understanding the patterns of what the scammers are trying to do
它们是一种合理的培训形式。它们还有助于生成一些信息，例如有25%的同事落入了这类陷阱，如果知道了易受骗的规模，这也许能更广泛地提高人们的意识。各种研究发现，有高得惊人的比例的人愿意将他们的密码和其他凭证交出来。给这类骗局。但它们并不是永久的解决方案。我认为，如果有永久的解决方案的话，它确实需要理解骗局制造者的意图模式
and what in particular they're trying to target about our own habits and trying to react to that more. There's also a downside to constantly doing that sort of check, which is it makes you distrust emails that seem to be coming from your own administration and your own company. So if you're constantly getting faked emails, it makes you kind of like, well, should I believe that this actual administrative email is genuine? Or do I just need to assume that they're suspicious of us all the time? So there's some potential backside to that.
以及他们具体想针对我们的哪些习惯进行攻击，并对此做出更多反应。不断进行这种检查也有一个缺点，那就是它会让你对似乎来自你自己的行政部门和你自己的公司的电子邮件产生不信任。因此，如果你经常收到虚假的电子邮件，就会让你觉得，好吧，我该相信这个实际的行政电子邮件是真的吗？还是我需要时刻假定他们对我们抱有怀疑？所以，这确实有一些潜在的负面影响。
But training people to recognize the hallmarks of that sort of scam and that sort of fishing is a really useful thing to do. So to wrap up, I want to ask you both, has working on this book and doing this research changed any of your own? habits, has it made you less trusting or more trusting in life? I do think that having looked at such a wide variety of different kinds of cons and scams throughout history, I learned a lot about ones that I never knew about, and it definitely, I would say, has made me more suspicious, hopefully not in a bad way, but also I think made me a little better at recognizing the patterns that you see among these things, so that when you you see some new offer or some new thing, a new story or whatever, you can sort of put it to a
但培训人们识别这种骗局和网络钓鱼的特征是一件非常有用事情。因此，在结束之际，我想问两位于，编写这本书和进行这项研究是否改变了你们自身的任何习惯？这是否让你在生活中变得不那么信任还是更加信任？我确实认为，通过回顾历史上形形色色的各种骗局和诡计，我了解了很多以前从未听说的骗局，这绝对可以说让我变得更加多疑，希望不是以一种不好的方式，同时也让我稍微更擅长识别这些事情中表现出来的模式，这样当你看到某种新的优惠、新的事物、新的故事或任何东西时，你就可以把它放入一个
framework, you know, where you say, oh, I understand what they're doing in this thing. And that makes it easier to classify, easier to remember, easier to think about like how you might avoid it or what you might advise somebody else to do. So I think overall it's quite, it's been quite a positive, even though on occasion it has been dismaying to see what people are doing and what people are falling for. And I think one of the big challenges in this sort of a context is thinking about when you need to be more skeptical, when you need to be more critical, because you can't be a skeptic all the time. That would be a terrible way to go through life, right?
框架中，你知道，你可以说，哦，我明白他们在这件事上在搞什么鬼了。这使得它更容易分类、更容易记住、更容易思考你该如何避开它或者你应该建议别人怎么做。所以我认为总体而言它相当，它相当积极，尽管有时看到人们在做什么以及人们在掉进什么陷阱里会让人感到沮丧。我认为在这种背景下的巨大挑战之一，是思考你何时需要更加怀疑，何时需要更加批判，因为你不可能时刻都保持怀疑。那将是一种糟糕的生活方式，对吧？
You'd be constantly cynical about everybody and everything. But knowing when it actually matters and thinking about when this could be consequential for me, I think that's been something that looking through all of these sorts of different scams and over history, it gives you a sense of what the patterns are for big risks and helps you to kind of think about, okay, do I need to worry about whether the grocery store has given me exactly the price that they promised on the shelf? Well, you know, if a couple of pennies here and there don't matter to me, I can kind of give it a sense of, is this overall close enough? And I don't necessarily want to check everything in detail. So I can kind of let the sort of small scams and small deceptions that probably happen unintentionally all over the place, kind of let those go, not worry about them too much, and really think about it when there's something that could be very consequential.
你会对每个人和每件事都抱有持续的冷嘲热讽。但了解它何时真正重要，并思考这何时会对你产生重大影响，我认为这是通过审视历史上所有这些不同骗局后所获得的一种体验。它让你对大风险的模式有了感觉，并帮助你思考，好吧，我需要担心杂货店给我的价格是否完全是货架上承诺的价格吗？嗯，你知道，如果这里那里差了几分钱对我不重要的话，我可以判断这总体上是否足够接近。我不一定非要事无巨细地检查每一件事。因此，我可以放过那种到处可能无意中发生的小骗局和轻微欺骗，不必过于担心，而真正当遇到可能产生重大影响的事情时再去认真思考。
Well, Dr. Simon's Dr. Shabri, I want to thank you both for joining me today. This has been really interesting. Thanks. It's been fun chatting. Yeah, thanks for having us. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www.combeckycology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your favorite podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology
好的，西蒙博士、沙布里博士，非常感谢两位于今天加入我们的节目。这真的非常有趣。谢谢，聊天很愉快。是的，谢谢邀请我们。您可以在我们的网站 www.apa.org 或在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或您获取喜爱播客的任何地方找到《心理学之声》以前的节目。如果您喜欢我们的节目，请给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，您可以给我们发电子邮件：speaking of psychology
at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Relax and let Ralph's delivery handle your grocery shopping this week. We start with only the freshest items,
at APA.org。《心理学之声》由 Lee Wynerman 制作。我们的音响编辑是 Chris Condyenne。感谢您的收听。美国心理学会出品。我是金·米尔斯。放松一下，本周让拉尔夫的配送服务来帮您搞定杂货采购。我们只挑选最新鲜的商品，
then review your list and carefully choose each one. Then we pack it all up and deliver it in as little as 30 minutes, so you can feel confident it's what you ordered. Fresh groceries, with Ralph's delivery and pickup. And right now, you can save $20 on your first delivery or pickup order. Ralph's, fresh for everyone. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
然后核对您的清单并仔细挑选每一件商品。接着，我们将所有东西打包好，在短短 30 分钟内送达，让您确信这就是您所订购的商品。新鲜杂货，尽在拉尔夫的配送与自提服务。现在，您的首次配送或自提订单还可立减 20 美元。拉尔夫，新鲜为你。本期节目尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。